let's talk about these goofball kids
that were hanging out outside your crib
over the weekend it's difficult to put
together the sequence of events because
at one point you're in your car at one
point you're outside at one point you're
both in cars 11:30 in the morning I went
and walked to my vehicle not worried
about what I was wearing at the time and
I wasn't very coherent because I'm not
normally coherent without my morning
coffee my morning cup of joe look what I
did you right so I get my [ __ ] car
and [ __ ] I looked at her laughing his
two kids outside of my door with a
[ __ ] camera net now that's not enough
to get me out of character give me out
of my vehicle but then they stayed and
they started chanting some [ __ ] I think
it was Drake lyrics okay their car said
[ __ ] yo get your I kill one of you
[ __ ] but I realized they were children
so you know that's the end of that you
run them off and then that's that I
couldn't got my coffee I came back they
spent the entire day it wouldn't got
their friends I don't know maybe was a
pokeymon spot or some [ __ ] I don't know
what was happening what happened when
you open the door the first time cuz the
snapchat cuts out Joe Budden what they
kept doing was they kept parking three
houses down so I didn't know that I was
just chasing I chased them and then when
I realized they were kids I stopped and
that's all I'm getting a car and they
drove off I thought that would be the
end of that and then they continued to
do that for the rest of the day and
because I'm super petty in my head and
had absolutely nothing better to do on a
Sunday I said and because I'm a little
off sometimes I said I'm gonna catch one
of [ __ ] and I'm gonna bring them in
here and I'm a beat they [ __ ] ass
right and I said wait a minute Rick Ross
do something like that you got a lot of
trouble you big headache I said look
slow down then I said wait a minute I
could go out here
with my gun shoot somebody now a real
been that I'm sure nope nope won't join
me nope nope and I thought a big shot in
the air it could have all been bad cuz
I'm a little off so when you filter your
craziness you come up with let me chase
the kid with rocks and give them a stern
warning I'm sorry for that I'm sorry and
that's what I did then I went to their
house the next morning how'd you know
where they live because the Internet
will tell you everything that you need
to know about something so you found out
where they live and then you came to the
house yeah cuz I have a 15 year old
these kids were 15 16 I found out if my
kid were behaving in a manner that would
get his [ __ ] head popped off I surely
would hope a parent would come tell me
so that's what I did I went there to go
speak to a parent or someone who loves
that kid did you end up talking to
somebody's mom or the mom came to the
door and I looked probably threatening
and she went and got his four brothers
and I had my conversation with all of it
except for the gentleman that was going
to [ __ ] you the day before but I spoke
to the brothers we all had a nice
understanding and if this is your
brother
we should probably rectify this more
importantly if y'all don't I met your
house the Internet's reaction to it is
always weird to me because there'll be
like all these memes and all the jokes
whatever which I guess is gonna happen
those memes were hilarious yes and you
said some of the funniest names I want
to show you some of the memes that
popped up and I want you to say that you
know the ones that you like the ones
that you don't like I just weren't sure
are they all right laughs top please
just look at the laptop oh this is kind
of fun now it is yeah once we stop
talking about [ __ ] break it's
wonderful